foreign
[Music]
the good news about the collapse of the
traditional Legacy Media is that new
media is moving to fill the void they
left behind and lives of tick tock is
honestly well it's a Twitter account but
it's become one of the most important
sites of reporting in the New Media and
essentially what lives of tick tock does
is find videos that people have posted
online about themselves publicly and
hold them up for a bigger audience lives
of tick tock is one of the reasons we
know what's happening in classrooms
around the country right now here's a
sample I have had multiple students come
out to be not just with their sexuality
but also with their gender identity it's
one of the reasons I think it's so
important to be out and loud and proud I
teach my elementary school students
about gender identity some people are
girls some are boys some are both some
are neither I might tell this kid we do
have a flag in the class that you can
Pledge Your Allegiance to and he like
looks around he goes oh that one
so there's something really wrong in the
country and in our classrooms kids are
being exposed to this without the
knowledge of their parents and we
wouldn't even know that written not in a
lot of cases for the reporting of Libs
of tick tock who by the way it doesn't
editorialize much just holds up what
people have said about themselves
for doing this the left has really tried
to hurt the person who runs Loops of
tick tock Taylor Lorenz of the
Washington Post wrote a whole piece
trying to find out who this person is so
other people could harass her well the
person who runs Libs of tick tock just
sat down with us and for the first time
revealed her identity for a new episode
Tucker Carlson today here's part of it
people ask me all the time this is my
one of the most common questions is if
you could say one thing to Taylor what
would it be or if you can ask her one
question and I I thought about this so
much and I always I wasn't I was never
sure how to answer the question and I
thought about it a lot and then I
realized the answer is
I don't want to talk to her she's a bad
person and she's toxic and I don't want
to we agree we disagree sorry we
disagree on everything there's we have
nothing in common she
she's not a person I ever want to be in
the same room with they never want to be
in her presence so there's my answer I
don't want to talk to her
so on Tuesday we're gonna take that off
her face and you will see for the first
time who runs lives of tick tock she
will be public and we think a force in
American Media that's going to happen
Tuesday right here on this show the
whole interview drops that day on Fox
Nation we hope you watch
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight